our next guest made so many headlines
this summer here are just a few
these three women toured the country
together on a bus bonded by something
they never imagined they'd have in
common
they all had the same cheating boyfriend
at the same time
i have got lots of questions so let's
get into it please welcome from inside
their bus in cedar city utah right now
morgan tabor abby roberts and becca king
[Applause]
well
let's start at the beginning morgan
when did you realize that your boyfriend
was cheating on you so it was the end of
uh 2020 in december i have been joking
about how this year couldn't get worse
and then it did
um i had a really weird feeling um i
feels like the universe or god or
something just trying to tell me like
something's off so i did some deep
diving and i found my boyfriend in
photos with another girl and i reached
out to her and she was like whoa um this
is insane we're comparing timelines she
sends me abby's instagram profile and
said hey we should look into her too
because if you're real she's probably
real too
she was
okay abby what went through your mind
when morgan reached out to you to tell
you that you've been dating her
boyfriend
i was absolutely shocked um it was such
a bizarre experience because he had
literally like woken up at my house that
morning and so um it was just really
awful and heartbreaking to find out that
he was not who i thought he was
morgan how did you confront him so i was
on a long facetime call with a few of
the girls minus becca that we had found
so i get a knock on my front door and
it's him and i have the girls on the
call and i say hey it's show time i put
my phone on the counter and i leave the
phone on then uh he asked me how my day
went and i said oh it's been amazing
i've actually made some new friends as i
grab my phone counter i flip it in his
face to the girls on the call and it was
a cinematic moment i mean his face yes
yes good
oh gosh
becca like how did you find out that you
also shared the same boyfriend with abby
and morgan
the day after they had had this
confrontation with him uh i get a
message on instagram
in a big group chat
and um
we start talking and at first i was
pretty skeptical because i i mean the
guy i knew
wouldn't have ever done this but of
course he did
okay
i love
that you took this negative and it is a
negative in my opinion i really wish
this person did not do that to anyone um
what i
come full circle with
is what you guys did in the end tell me
about how the road trip idea came about
so it was actually four days after we
had all met each other
uh christmas eve to be specific um we
started talking about our dreams and
uh traveling was a big one for all of us
and
we were discussing different rigs we'd
wanna like go on a road trip in and then
i remember i had family friends that are
selling school buses so i reached out to
them and they were like yeah you can
come take a look at some of them and
from there things just started to fall
and they started falling into place
which was really beautiful in the midst
of feeling like our lives were falling
apart and we were like whoa this is
really beautiful because we have
something awesome we can look forward to
and i quickly learned with these girls
that when they say they're going to do
something they will do it
and that is how we're here now
abby i'd love to just quickly from each
one of you what do you have to say to
someone who has been through
a broken heart and gets you know
blindsided advice so i think um the
biggest advice i would give is just like
you are not defined by what they did to
you um and the quicker you can realize
that and put your energy into positive
things and and move past it you will
become
so much more empowered and so much more
able to
seek new opportunities and to really
make something beautiful
okay and uh becca will you contribute a
thought because i loved that
i think something i've learned on this
road trip is how important it is to have
people that like to surround yourself
with
um that are going through similar things
or at least can understand what you've
been through um dealing with all of
what we
what had happened was a lot better when
we had each other i think and morgan i
think not only is it important to mourn
the loss of
a person and go through all those stages
of grief as you do it's very healthy um
and to not be stuck in it but to
remember that especially with our
situation that all of our timelines look
a little bit different for healing um
it's not like a one-size-fits-all so
that was a very big lesson that i
learned that it was taking me a little
longer um and that's completely okay
because there is no timeline on healing
i agree i don't think there's a timeline
on healing but i think there is uh not
staying stuck either and that's why i
love your story so much um so we want to
send you guys a big supply of tea and
coffee because also like i heard you
guys i i need my caffeine and um
it's a lifeline i know that oh my gosh
that would be wonderful thank you
and i'm also just going to send you 10
000 just to like i don't know where see
where you go next
where are you going next
and
wherever you go next
i'm wondering if you will check in with
us and report the next bout of wisdom
that you've gained
great
excellent
thank you
and um
thank you for sharing your story with
everyone um like i said i think it's a
fantastic road map um also um
you guys can i share that coffee with
you in celebration of our new york week
we want to give away some of our very
favorite things and um everyone's going
to get a year's supply of coffee and tea
thanks to barney's coffee and tea
company
and
i would be i don't know where i'd be
without my caffeine and they just pride
themselves on their unique flavors
ranging from german chocolate cake yes
please to pumpkin spice everyone's
favorite
um and um
like i said we're gonna check back in
with you in another city and just see
what you're up to next
thank you so much thank you so much oh
my god i just love you guys thank you so
much
[Music]
you